who puts that
who puts that
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by the undertaker mark callaway
he's a seven time world heavyweight
champion one of the greatest
professional wrestlers of all time
his five-part docu-series the last ride
is currently airing on wwe network and
on november 22nd he'll be giving his
final farewell at survivor series
the same event where he made his debut
more than 30 years ago
taker welcome to the show sean man how
you doing brother
i'm doing great i know that you're a
texas boy
how do you like your food do you like it
spicy yeah i like spicy food but
i like it to have flavor i'm just gonna
be straight up like
you know where i come from in my family
we have uh
crawfish boils and all that which you
know you got sausage you got all these
shrimp and all these different things
and it's spicy as hell but it tastes
good if it's got a flavor and it tastes
good that's one thing but uh just
drinking liquid liquid kerosene i'm not
uh yeah we'll see how this goes
you're probably gonna start me out with
the scorcher no no
no no we're not playing that game with
you we'll work our way there though
all right i mean i don't know if you can
see that is that is that sufficient
that looks good to me all right man you
ready
i'm ready cheers
[Music]
that's actually pretty good
[Music]
i'm actually hungry so it's really going
to suck at the end of this thing i'm
sure
so as someone who didn't break character
for three decades it's been really
interesting to watch you pull back the
curtain for the first time in your wwe
docu-series and now in this recent run
of interviews
i'm sure you've been asked this before
but has the experience of knocking down
that fourth wall over the last year
has it been cathartic or mostly just
disorienting
you know it's a really great question
you know i've been in the wrestling
business for over 30 years and
30 years with wwe on the 22nd
but i'm a notoriously old-school guy
and you know talking about the business
so openly
it's still to this day i i'm kind of
like oh [ __ ]
i'm fighting that urge to you know to
clam up and not talk about it and force
myself like
getting tell stories you know and people
are dying to hear this stuff
so you know that aspect it's fun but
just the old school
the old school wrestler is uh it's like
man you should just
go back pull the curtains shut and and
tell everybody you're not home
but so it's it's been a mix of both
it was such a serious character but i do
remember your appearances in particular
on regis and kelly in the 90s and i'm
curious did you get a kick
out of being on those daytime tv shows
and just sort of growling and grunting
through interviews
absolutely miserable
like back then in those early 90s i got
no juice then
right i'm just i'm just another one of
the guys
and when when the boss says hey we want
you to go and read this and kathy lee
you go on regis and kathy lee i remember
the first time that we did the show
man here she comes she starts piping off
and i'm just like
i i hated it i did i knew it was good
for business but
for my character and for me personally i
was absolutely
miserable
that's different from your traditional
kind of sausage that's good
so like stand-up comedians the wrestling
origin story is something that we obsess
about on this show
what do you remember about performing
under the name commando in a league
called
central illinois wrestling wow
man you've done some homework brother
i'll give you this you're the first
person that's ever asked me that
question
kudos to you because i've answered a lot
of the same questions
over the last year i've answered the
same question a lot so good for you
um so starving to death
i was making absolutely no money i look
back on those
experiences and those times really
fondly and never forgotten because it
was a struggle
you know because a lot of times guys get
up to the show they make a little you
know they get a little scratch and
you know they change completely changed
my dad gave me some great advice uh a
long time ago
he goes the toes you step on on the way
to the top
are connected to the asses you're going
to have to kiss on the way back down
so you know i'd like to i try to treat
people the same
as i treated them then the way i you
know i tried to shoot them now the way i
treated them then
and still like remember what it's like
to
get those those missing meal cramps you
know
[Music]
it's got a little kick a little faster i
didn't even get all the way into the
bite and i could already feel the heat
that's that's how it'll go that's how it
will go going forward
okay i'm ready i think
so you're a true historian of
professional wrestling and in hearing
you speak candidly about those you've
shared a locker room with it's clear
that you have a profound appreciation
for the business
who was the best technical wrestler you
ever saw work
technical wow um
who you what arn anderson
aaron anderson is up there he was so
solid in every fast
cut unbelievable promos on just
technical ability
i'm gonna go with arners who would you
say was the most impressive
physical athlete that you ever saw
brock lesnar you don't think a human
being can move
that fast at that size he was a freak
athlete he really was
as someone who enjoys a good laugh who
was the most savage
backstage prankster
well there's there's a level um to
to to pranksters they're you know
they're i mean you have to put
you got to put kurt henning up there as
a uh
all-time classic river um
food then you got the kind of ribs that
you know will start fights which you
know like mr fuji
you know guys would like try and rip me
back and it just escalate and escalate
until
people would think like i've really made
a bad mistake because there's a
there's a animal's head in my gear bag
now i mean it's mean that's
i mean i i won't get into details but uh
there there are some stories about
if regular people were to hear them
they were just like they'd be appalled
at some of the uh
some of the pranks but owen heart my
goodness oh man god rest your soul
but what a river owen heart was i know
that this puts you on the spot and i
don't want you to
overthink it i don't want you to think
it over too much but
if a wrestling novice wanted a
foundation of the best that there is in
sports entertainment
can you give me four defining wrestling
matches that you'd recommend they try to
track down and watch on youtube
yeah i think so um i would go with
uh randy savage and ricky steamboat
any match between ric flair and harley
raves
a little bit of a egomaniac here but i
would put undertaker shawn michaels
wrestlemania
25 modern day was the recent match
between
edge and randy orton those are four that
kind of encapsulates
uh what we do and it's at its highest
level
[Music]
it kind of sneaks up on you on the back
end lets you know why the goat's so
angry
it kind of tricks you like oh man that's
good
and then uh yeah the goat kind of
jumps up and kicks in the ass
so jim ross dubbed you the conscience of
the wwe and it's clear from listening to
interviews with your peers in the
business that you're revered not only as
a wrestler but also as a leader in the
locker room
i don't know if this is true or not so i
guess i'll take it right to the source
but were you ever like
a judge in a locker room kangaroo court
where if like two wrestlers had beef
with each other they would like come to
like a more
formal ceremonial thing and then if
maybe they lost
the the lawsuit against them or they
lost the case against them they'd have
to like
buy beer for the winner or something
like that well i take exception with the
word kangaroo
i don't want this i don't want the smoke
i don't want i don't want any smoke i
don't want any smoke you know
this is a virtual kind of deal and
you're feeling kind of brave but uh
wrestlers court no no i tease
uh you know you know wrestler's
coordinate was kind of a way
now sometimes it was really serious it
was a friendly way
a light-hearted way to kind of say look
you need to check yourself
because everybody's noticing you just
don't get brought up to wrestlers court
because
you're going out and working your butt
off every night and you know you go on
about your business there's usually a
pretty good reason to get brought up to
wrestlers court
you know they say you see it all the
time but we call it gimmick infringement
where one guy will do another guy's move
and
uh you know that
guys get hot more so back in the earlier
days than they do now
but i mean it used to be like if you did
somebody else's move
yeah there could be very well could be a
scrap if you let it go too long
so you know you got to keep all that
stuff in
check or it'll get out of hand real
quick
[Music]
that's good yeah i like that man
that's my favorite so far hey we'll take
it
all right i'm gonna take a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram where you do a deep dive on our
guests instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context and with you today we have a
theme
it's pictures with past hot ones guests
so i'll show you the picture you just
tell us the bigger story
first things first what do you remember
about meeting fellow beer enthusiast
post malone in austin texas
yeah uh so that was the the start of my
my ig career where it was right after
that i think that was my first post
uh with post and was crazy
a crazy wrestling fan he was
i mean he started rattling things off i
think part of his life he was in new
york right he grew up there so he had
all that knowledge and then he's a texas
guy you know he had that knowledge
he was really fun to talk to but man it
was just fun
it was fun watching his face kind of
light up getting to talk about wrestling
and being a kid again
so real really really cool down to earth
guy
here you are face off with stone cold
steve
austin what do you think is your best
match against stone gold
probably the most memorable would be
summerslam uh
highway to hell that was so cool to
build up to that
um it was in madison square garden uh
you know they had this big highway to
hell build up and we were
all buses we're on billboards we're
everywhere
the match was okay but the build up and
the hype around it was was awesome i
i damn near knocked steve out that night
inadvertently
of all things you know my head hit him
right in the chin and
his eyes rolled like a slot machine and
it took a few minutes to get you know to
get steve back with us
but uh yeah it was fun anytime you got a
chance to work with
stone cold man it was it was a good
night here you are college game day
supporting your longhorns earlier this
season we had matthew mcconaughey on the
show
have you ever had an on campus run in
with mcconaughey or anything like that
oh yeah so in that night at the game
against lsu uh i think both of us were
talking
way too much smack um
we just we were just really confident
that texas was going to beat lsu
obviously i'm glad since we lost that
they went on to win the national title
but uh later that year mcconaughey
brought his kids down
to the show in austin and uh we actually
sat backstage and talked for a while uh
it really laid back texas dude you know
just as chill as can be
say man you gotta join be like cooler if
you did
this one's gonna be legit i'm sure
that's how you get a chicken wing you
don't tear it off with your hands
not going to mention any names but
anyway that's how you eat a chicken wing
so even against the rich history of
entry music and wrestling you arguably
lay claim to the most recognizable
walkout songs of all time
your original funeral theme in the 90s
was based on a piano piece by chopin
but with sinister organs and chimes what
was the evolution of that first version
and was it made by wwe producer jim
johnston
it was yeah he he was man he he had a
long long run with us
and um he's just so creative
and what was so good about him is you
know after he would put something
together
you know he would want your input onto
on it there was a timer there was
actually a really
nasty guitar riff as that character
morphed
and evolved the gong at the beginning is
so iconic you know i mean everything has
to start with that
and then you can tweak and add things to
it as you go along but uh
yeah jim was jim was really good and i
enjoyed working with him
involved in evolving the entrance
through the years
yeah and even stylistically as things
changed you had walkout songs to
kid rock you had walkout songs to learn
biscuit metallica
johnny cash looking back which of your
walkout
songs outside of that original got the
biggest pop from fans
you know when i came out in seattle for
that wrestlemania to lift biscuit
they played me in live i mean that was
that was
that was pretty charged up but i'd have
to i'd have to go with kid rock's uh
american badass that was there was just
so much energy
with that song and you know with me
calling myself the american badass i
mean it just fit perfectly the whole
the lyrics everything was just spot-on
it's got bourbon in it yeah that's all
you had to say
might have tripped me there i went a
little extra with so she said it was
bourbon
oh yeah i'm gonna probably regret that
trapped you wow
you get it right away yep
and the heat ain't far behind it still
going in though you must like it i'm
hungry man
i'm hungry and i like bourbon
so you famously protected the undertaker
character to the point of turning down
interviews and movie roles that could
spoil the mystique
but now that you've broken down the
fourth wall we want to fact check some
notable
undertaker folk tales fact or fiction
you wrestled in the 2010 elimination
chamber with second-degree burns on your
chest from an accident involving
pyrotechnics
absolutely a couple of weeks prior
um during one of my entrances
you know that bourbon sticking around
for a while
um my pyro bursts they were getting them
really close to me
i went to the pyro guy and i said look
the pyroburst when i'm at the edge of
the stage
they need to be moved back a little bit
the pyro kind of blew me off about it
and
so when the pyro comes up i mean it's on
me right so
it forces me to turn to my right
and as soon as i turn to my right the
right pipe will burst come up
so i'm totally just like my lips right
now engulfed in flame
i could see fire on my hat you know
famously
the announcers are trying to he's you
know he's so fired up to get in there
he's kind of running to the ring
i was on fire and i was trying to put
myself out you know
i was in the ring with chris jericho
and you know he's got me in he's got me
in the walls of jericho where his my
chest is completely flat against the mat
right and he's he's just
working me over right and pulling me and
tugging me and this is my foot my burnt
chest is just rubbing up against that
canvas mat and uh later that night
you know i think i kind of wanted a
little bit of shock and yeah i don't
recommend it
i i really don't if anybody's ever
thinking about doing that for an
entrance don't do it it's not good is it
true that
jim ross once pitched a pay-per-view
between you and mankind it was called a
boiler room brawl and it was going to be
live from alcatraz do you have any
knowledge of that
yeah we we mankind and i had so many
themed matches boiler room brawl hell on
the cell
buried alive we had you know we were two
characters that
those matches really lent themselves to
yeah jim ross was always like i could
see you guys you know if you could ever
get to alcatraz
the only way to win the match is to
escape alcatraz and
you know we just never can make it
happen uh
but i was always on board for that i
just thought that would have been the
coolest thing
ever to do and then finally fact or
fiction your mom
scolded shane mcmahon when he punched
you in the face and drew blood
my mom scolded a lot of people i had to
it got to the point i had to quit uh
i had to quit bringing her to the shows
when i'd go to houston
i remember it is true by the way yes
and she will cuss triple h to this day 6
10
320 pounds i'm still the baby right i'm
still her baby and she thinks she has to
help me
it was wrestlemania and dallas that's
where i wrestled shane and held the cell
so she was exposed to everybody that she
had seen on tv
and i think she kept promos on just
about everybody she didn't like
[Music]
very hot very high oh okay
you're not even you're not even going to
try and lie about it you're just telling
me straight up
[Music]
that is stupid very stupid
why i think
for this show only it tastes like a
yak's ass
on fire wow
it is this it's not even it's not even
hit its peak yet
it's still growing still growing yeah
it's still it's smoldering and it's it's
just
yeah it's uh
there are the hiccups yep i know those
all too well
[Music]
who puts that who puts that on
out of uh out of kansas city if you're
if you're if you're curious
that is brutal
wow so you've amassed a formidable
collection of motorcycles over the years
if your garage caught on fire and you
could only save the bike
that means the most to you which one
would you save
um it would probably have been that my
uh my west coast chopper
jesse built for me it was just an
amazing build amazing
bike and uh that one or the or the very
first bike that i bought
once i got out of debt from getting into
this business
that was kind of the first thing that i
that i ever bought myself was a brand
new harley
in the famous book zen in the art of
motorcycle maintenance the author writes
it's the sides of the mountain which
sustain life
not the top does riding have a spiritual
transcendent dimension for you
absolutely
it does it's just especially like when
you're on like
if you're on like the pch or or
someplace where you can just let you you
can just go
you're not having to worry so much about
you know all the traffic and all cars
and you just
get on the road and i'm not like a zen
guy but
it's i guess that's what i can equate it
to everything kind of goes away and
you're just right there
in the moment i'm loving what i'm doing
right now and
i wish it could last forever my goal is
actually not to drink the milk
well you know what we're on that fast
track because we only have two more to
go
and so far you haven't touched it are
you ready to move on to the next sauce
it's the chocolate express from pucker
bud
sucker well i can tell you one thing my
butt is puckered
[Music]
but if you want to be the boss you got
to use the sauce right
that's what they say
yeah that's going to be stupid hot
well while it builds i'll wind you up
gonna take it a minute but i can feel it
you know mike tyson once said i was the
youngest heavyweight
champion of all time but the most fun i
ever had in the ring was with wwe
is a boxing die hard yourself what do
you see as tyson's lasting
impact on professional wrestling as a
whole
he gave i mean he gave us an era of
legitimacy
uh because he was he was the most
covered athlete in the world
we had been getting our butts handed to
us from wcw
and you know they were killing us
everywhere we finally rebuilt our roster
and
it was it was absolutely the turning
point uh
of where we never looked back again i
mean it really was
we were on the fast track and it was it
was probably one of the greatest eras
ever in wrestling
in my opinion
[Music]
the last dab oh this is gonna be
horrible i can tell
[Music]
[Music]
strength to strength to strength here
with the blast three but it's okay
because taker
here we are at the final bell of our ten
round hell in a zoom
cell match with the wings of death and
this weekend you'll be giving your final
farewell
survivor series capping off a legendary
career that spans more than three
decades
and one of the reasons i think that
you've been such an iron horse in this
industry
is the razor-sharp understanding you
have of your fans i've heard you say
that there are guys who can do
phenomenal things athletically
but never have a successful career
because they can't identify with their
audience
if sunday's bout is indeed your last how
do you want those
undertaker fans to remember you as a
wrestler
i think the biggest thing that i want
people to understand is
is how much they
uh how much they were
so instrumental in getting me through so
much
and how much it how important it was to
me to get out there
and perform i'll look back and say that
i never phoned anything
in i gave everybody everything that i
had and always
thought about the people that were
coming to see me and they were paying
their hard-earned dollars sometimes
really rough times to come see me
perform
and see us perform so i just want people
to understand how
important it was for me to be the
undertaker and give
people that little bit of time to escape
the real world and uh and be able to do
it for so many
years and that goes back to the fans for
keeping me relevant and
keeping me near and dear to their hearts
i just it was never lost on me and
means the world to me what a ride it has
been
and speaking of wild rides look at you
taking on the hot ones gauntlet had a
goal of no milk
and i see that those glasses are still
full to the brim
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you undertaker
this camera that camera probably just
the one that you're looking at
let the people know what you have going
on in your life well we're moving into
survivor series which will mark my 30th
year
with the wwe um the final farewell
it's going to be a phenomenal
pay-per-view if you haven't checked out
the last ride
it's me bearing my soul and uh
and and just giving you everything i
think that people have wanted to see for
so long
uh so that that's the goal man we're
trying to get to
uh try to get to that 30-year
anniversary and uh
see what happens next
as painful as it was i really enjoyed
this man it was a good time thank you
this is getting re-gifted
did the bomb is getting re-gifted to
somebody
oh my gosh
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in to say thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and i have an exciting announcement
a very exciting announcement feast your
eyes
on the hot ones reebok collab
i am so excited for this collaboration
you have the club c
you have the classic leather and of
course the shack gnosis
now you can do the shack face in style
the weight was intended let me walk you
through my favorite features on each one
first off with the club c i love that
it's the color of milk
on the back you have this cool hot ones
logo with the scoville scale and i love
how the reebok logo it's kind of like
the lower third that we put with
guests that is our mild our milk
and then up next we have the classic
leather it's our medium
it has the scoville scale along the side
i like the scoville scale on the tongue
it comes in at 198 300 scoville units
1983 the year the classic leather was
dropped
and that's what i love about these shoes
everything has such purpose
right down to the five wings on the
bottom of the sole
wear them both and you have a full hot
ones gauntlet
and finally the shacknosis classic
shacknosis shoe hot ones on the back
cranked all the way up to 11 just like
the shack episode
and then you have the scoville scale
colorway different color
laces the hot ones reebok collab we are
so
so proud reebok.com reebok.com
reebok.com to get your hands on the hot
ones reebok collab
even the box has milk and wings all over
it
hot ones reebok put them on your feet
baby